Transcriber: malak wahid
المدقّق: Mohamed Salem
سنة ألفين وخمسة كنت صف تاسع وقتها جبنا أول
جهاز كمبيوتر علي البيت
بعد ما اتركب الجهاز واشتغل
أعطاني المهندس وسيديهات قالي انهم
مهمين كتير احتفظ فيها ولا تضيعهم
لا تضعهم في الكمبيوتر لأنه راح خربه
طبعا بعد ما راح المهندس
اول شئ عملته وضعتهم في الكومبيوتر
هذه اللحظة كانت نقطة انطلاقة رحلتي
مع عالم البرمجة والانترنت.
مرحبا انا محمد ديوب جاء اليوم أحكي لكم
عن تجربتي مع التعلم الذاتي
و العمل عبر الانترنت.
تعلمت البرمجة بشكل ذاتي عبر الانترنت.
ولعل الانترنت يسمح لكم تصلوا إلى كمية
هائلة من المصادر والمراجع والمعلومات
والدورات التدريبية ، فهو يعتبر مصدر تعلم
مهم جدا سواء كنادي في دراستك الأكاديمية
أو لتعلم أي مهارة جديدة من الصفر تماما.
وفقا لمركز الأبحاث الأميركي ، يقول إن
التعلم عبر الإنترنت يزيد من معدلات
استبقاء المعلومات بنسبة تتراوح بين خمسة
وعشرين إلى ستين بالمئة
مقارنه بالتعلم وجها لوجه الي نسبة استبقاء
المعلومات فيه منخفضة جدا
وتترواح بين ثمانية و عشره بالمئة.
هذا الشيء أو هذا السبب هذه بالخروقات
بيناتنهم يرجع لعدة أسباب أولها أن نتعلم
عبر الإنترنيت يعطي الطلاب إمكانية التحكم
بعملية سرعة التعلم ، إضافة الى أنه يعطي
فرصة حتى يرجع إلى طلوعه على
مواد التدريب وقت الحاجة.
شخصيا اقدر اقول أنه تقريبا كل شئ تعلمته
بحياتي كان بشكل ذاتي عبر الإنترنت.
بسنة ألفين وثمانية كنت طالب
بكالوريا غير مجتهد.
وبما أنني بمرحلة تحديد مستقبل فكنت دائما
أسمع عبارات من قبيل طيب انت ما تعلمت مهنة
ولا مهتم بدراستك شرح تساوي ، كيف بدك
تعيش ؟ كيف بدك تكفي حياتك ؟ كان جوابي
ببساطة أنا راح اشتغل على الانترنت.
طبعا بها ديك الفترة ألفين وثمانية.
كان انترنت بسوريا لسه بدايته في كثير
ناس ما سمعت عنه ولا تعاملت معه مسبقا،
انا كيف بدي اشتغل علي الانترنت
هل هذا الشئ ممكن اساسا
لكن انا كنت مؤمن ان العمل عبر الانترنت
هو المستقبل
لسبب كثير بسيط أنه عندما تكون عايش
بإحدى دول العالم الثالث
فأنت ببساطة عندك ميزة كتير مهمة وهي
أنك ترى مستقبل بلادك عم يطبق حاليا أمام
عينك بالدول المتقدمة ، ومن هذا المنطلق كنت
مؤمن أن العمل عبر الإنترنت
هو سيكون المستقبل.
من حوالي سبع سنين كان كل شيء يملكه من
وسائل التكنولوجيا هو موبايل آندرويد الصغير
طبعا كان من المستحيل أن يستخدموا بالبرمجة
فكرت اني  اساوي لفه مهنيه
اتعلم الغه الإنجليزية واتعلم الترجمة.
استخدمت الإنترنت كوسيلة لاكتساب المهارات
الجديدة قدرة عدد كبير من المحاضرات
والدورات التدريبية.
قرأت كتب أون لاين لأساتذة جامعيين ولا
مترجمين مخضرم،
اضافه اني ساوت مدونه اتدرب صرت فيها
وترجم مقالات عامة
وبعد عدة أشهر من ممارسة التعلم والتدريب
اخذت الخطوة التالية.
صرت اشتغل كمترجم أون لاين.
بعدها بحوالي سنتين قدرت جيب لاب
رجع شغف البرمجة يظهر من جديد
لكن كان معلوماتي البرمجية صارت قديمة ناقصه
فمجددا استخدمت الانترنت كوسيلة
لترميم معلوماتي البرمجية.
وبعد فترة من التدرب حضور عدة كورسات أون
لاين رجعت كمبرمج عبر الإنترنت.
لاحقا دمجت خبرتي في البرمجة والترجمة مع
بعض لإنشاء منصة موجهة للأشخاص اللي حبين
يتدربوا على الترجمة سواء كانوا طلاب أو
كانوا أشخاص يتعلمون الترجمة بشكل ذاتي.
حاليا قطاع العمل الحر ينمو بشكل كبير سريع
جدا،
فوفقا لدراسة موقع  up work موقع
اللي هو موقع المستقليين
بتقول إنه يمثل المستقلين حاليا ستة
وثلاثين بالمئة من القوى العاملة بالولايات
المتحدة أي أنه واحد من كل ثلاثة أمريكيين
هو يشتغل بشكل مستقل
سواء بدوام كامل أو كعمل إضافي جزئي .
وهذا الرقم بازدياد كبير
خصوصا بعد أزمة فيروس كورونا
التي أجبرت ملايين الناس حول العالم
على أن يتركوا وظائفهم يقعودوا ببيوتهم
وجعلتهم يجرب العمل عبر الانترنت سواء
كرغبة منهم أو مجبرين .
لكن لماذا انتشر العمل عبر الانترنت ؟ ما
هي الأسباب التي جعلت أسلوب العمل هناك
ينتشر بهذا الشكل الواسع ؟ على عندما نستعرض
الأسباب فنحن لدينا طرفين في العمل
عندنا صاحب العمل أو الشركات ، وعندنا
مستقلين للأشخاص يشتغل .
فمن وجهة نظر الشركات فالعمل عبر الإنترنت
يسمح لهم أن
يوصف كفاءات حول العالم بأجور منخفضة
كما يقلل من تكاليف البنية التحتية
التي مفترض أن يوفروا للموظفين مثل
التكاليف اللوجستية تكاليف المكتبي
وبأذار ألفين وتسعة عشر
أو اعتبارا من آذار ألفين و تسعه عشر .
صار عدد المستقلين المتعاقدين مع شركة غوغل
أكبر من عدد موظفين دائمين لديها .
أما من وجهة نظر المستقلين ، فالعمل عبر
الإنترنت يوفر لهم مصدر دخل جيد
يعطي مرونة كبيرة بالعمل بعيدا عن الضغوطات
، كما يسمحلمن يشتغلوا مع أي مكان أو
سوق حول العالم
بالتالي مستقل حرفيا .
قادر يشتغل من اينما كان
يأخذ شغله معه أينما
راح ؟ ياخذ شغله معه وين ما راح .
امكانية أن يأخذ شكله معه أينما رآح أدت
لظهور مصطلح جديد
الذي هو الرحالة الرقميين digital nomads.
لكن شو هنا الرحالة الرقميين.الرحالة رقميين
هم عبارة عن أشخاص يعيشون في بلدان ذات
تكاليف معيشة منخفضة ، واشتغلوا عبر
الإنترنت مع أسواق ذات اجور مرتفعة ،
بالتالي يصبح عندهم دخل عالي مصروف منخفض.
اليوم بسوريا كلنا ممكن يكون
رحالة رقميين.
والظروف الاقتصادية الصعبة التي سببتها
الأزمة السورية مثل البطالة المرتفعة ،
التضخم الكبير ، انخفاض الأجور
وغيرها من المشاكل .
العمل على الإنترنت هو الحل .
وكشخص يشتغل عبر الانترنيت من حوالي سبع
سنين ويعتمد عليه كمصدر دخل كامل ،
فأنا كثير فخور اني أخذ قرار العمل عبر
الانترنت وحاربت لحقوقه .
فخور أني قادرت اساوي شركة برمجيات .
كلا موظفينا يشتغلون أون لاين ، والأهم أنه
قدرت ادرب أكثر من خمسمائة شاب وصبية على
أن يشتغل أون لان بمختلف المجالات .
فعليا طالما العمل اللي ،انت تشتغله
قادر أن ترسل نتيجته أون لاين .
فهو صالح ليكون عمل عبر الإنترنت
سواء كان ترجمة . تصميم
تدقيق لغوي .
برمجة .
تعليق صوتي .
إلى آخره .
أي عمل كان ؟ أنا أعرف معظم
كونهم يدونه بلا سؤال .
طيب يا أخي نحن كيف بدنا نجيب أرباحنا ؟
كيف نجيب المصاري ؟ كيف نشتغل بواقع
الكهرباء السيء ؟ وغيره من الأسئلة تتعلق
بالمشاكل التي نحن كلنا كسوريين عم نعاني
منها ؟ جوابي المختصر والبسيط
حيكون طالما أنت عايش
معاك موبايل وإنترنت فأنت قادر
تشتغل وتنجز كتأكيد على هذا الكلام .
احب اخبركم ان كل شئ حكيت لكم
و كل شئ اشتغلته.
اشتغلته خلال فترة خدمتي العسكرية
التي استمرت تسعة سنين
وشكرا .